bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors est un vrai danger
ou simplement leur part report dans le
calendrier quel impact selon vos de la
crise sanitaire dans le développement de
la 5g
bon alors évidemment il ya aujourd'hui
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
reportés avait avec la crise le
lancement de la 5g c'est extrêmement
important puisqu'on va faire un saut
qualitatif dans des technologies
nouvelles c'est pas simplement une
nouvelle génération c'est un saut
qualitatif dans une technologie qui va
permettre de nouveaux usages
donc c'est évidemment important de
lancer ça dans un contexte serein dans
un contexte où la reprise économique
sera assurée ou les divers opérateurs
pourront être à la fois en appui puis en
capacité de mobilisation donc
aujourd'hui on a une incertitude
économique évidemment avec la crise du
communisme de 19
je crois que c'est une
un record qui est salutaire et dans
quelle mesure est ce que cette crise
sanitaire peut avoir un impact sur le
marché de la saint john dans quelques
adresses qu'elles peuvent bénéficier aux
américains et quid aussi de la course
aux équipements entre américains et
chinois
bon je crois qu'il faut distinguer
vraiment deux choses soit distingué le
long terme il court terme encore une
fois à court terme c'est important de
lancer une technologie qui est quand
même ce qui est quand même
fondamentalement nouvelle en tout cas
aujourd'hui les attributions les
attributions aux la 5g de lancer dans un
contexte serein ça c est court terme sur
le long terme
c'est sûr qu'il ya aujourd'hui deux
offres techniques et commerciales qui
sont qui sont enquis sans présence
l'offre qui sont offertes de manière un
peu inégal c'est à dire l'offre chinoise
est assez avancé l'offre chinoise est
aussi économiquement intéressante
l'offre américaine est un petit peu
derrière alors peut-être que le court
terme peut donner l'occasion aux
entreprises américaines de continuer à
avancer dans leur dans leurs offres de
produits leurs offres de services
ça c'est une chose maintenant je suis
une chose économie a tant sur le plan
plus des réalités géostratégiques parce
que c'est ça dont il s'agit entre la
chine et les etats unis aujourd'hui qui
sont croissantes
il peut y avoir des enjeux sur
l'évolution de la réglementation aux
états unis dans l'intervalle et alors
aujourd'hui à ce que cette guerre
commerciale qui technologique qui se
joue entre la chine et les états unis
est ce qu'elle peut avoir
un impact positif et ce qu'elle peut
bénéficier aux acteurs européens alors
d'abord je crois vous avez mentionné de
guerre est mentionné une guerre
commerciale à une guerre technologique
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans le domaine
de la 5g la guerre commerciale peut
évoluer vers une guerre plus
technologique
il n'y avait guère commercial à
technologie d'années encore une fois je
le disais il ya deux forces en présence
et en tout cas deux offres de service et
deux heures de produits en présence et à
ce moment là il ya une rivalité
commerciale qui passe encore une fois
par la réglementation mais c'est au tour
d'offres commerciales qu'on développe
les choses s'il ya un délai plus
important pour mettre en place les
réglementations et on a fortiori aux
etats unis puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit également pas seulement en europe
et bien là il peut y avoir une
recrudescence des forts technologique de
la partie américaine qui voudraient
entre guillemets c'est de combler son
retard et donc là on peut rentrer dans
la guerre technologique et en
particulier on voit s'élever des voix
aux etats unis aujourd'hui pour que
l'industrie américaine les entreprises
américaines soit associée de manière
plus proche avec les pouvoirs
réglementaires aux états unis pour
j'allais lire un peu cow définir les
normes les normes réglementaires et ça
c'est assez nouveau
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions joël ruet je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste au
cnrs et président du think tank the
bridge donc